hey there kids welcome back to new
rockstars I'm Sam Bashan if you're
watching this video you've hopefully
just finished watching Justice League
whether you loved it you hated it your
middle the road which is crazy idea you
probably have some questions about the
post-credits scenes yes deuce don't
worry boys and girls new rockstars has
got you covered but be warned we're
getting into spoilers for the Justice
League movie other DC films comics TV
shows etc you're kids ready let's do it
now to be clear we're getting to post
credits scenes both fairly different the
first of them being one that hints to
the lighter turns of the DC you will be
taking from now on we see one of the
most iconic moments from DC Comics
coming to life on the big screen it's a
race between Superman and my boy the
flash I was pretty happy I'll be honest
now we didn't get a taste of this kind
of race before in the first season of
Supergirl vs. the CW flash and actually
a little bit on Smallville between Bart
Allen and Clark in season four all that
aside this is the first time on the big
screen we can see these two heroes
racing each other recreating that
classic moment from Superman number 199
from 1967 happened many times after that
but that was the original this feels
like a signal of a brighter future for
the DC Universe and maybe this could
have been no Joss Whedon's influence
maybe just a little bit he loves
characters you know having the fun
on-screen joking around and since we
don't know the outcome over the race it
was just you know hinted maybe this
leaves it open for jokes and future
movies maybe they hit like no I'm faster
faster classic Whedon I don't know I'm
always a fan a little bit of a rivalry
between characters I do enjoy the
chemistry between all these actors on
screen playing these characters and I
can't wait to see them in future films
now this was just the first of the after
credit scenes the second I am a
particular fan of because it makes me
very excited for the future of the DC
you it opens with the reveal that Lex
Luthor has escaped Arkham Asylum huh but
how this nefarious fiend how dare he the
surprises don't stop there no no we
follow a speedboat ducking with a yacht
in the middle of the sea with this new
player helping a board to reveal
Lex Luthor's on board already hmm who
could this mysterious figure be double
gasp it's Deathstroke oh my god who
could be playing Deathstroke you ask
three guests Joe Manganiello
the man that we've been speculating for
a long time to be playing Deathstroke
and he was confirmed a few months ago
but still it's true thank you Twitter
snoops you guys went through all the
farlows of Zack Snyder and other people
working on the Justice leaking yet found
it out but wanting back for a second
when Deathstroke hops aboard the yacht
Luthor mentions the return of Superman
and how he and Deathstroke should form
their own oh boy let's unpack this whole
thing for just a second so this is the
first official appearance of Deathstroke
in the DCU
yes I'm happy I loved it I loved the Joe
Manganiello is playing him I can't wait
for his solo movie if that's actually
going to happen because he deserves it
also if Gareth Evans the director behind
raid gets to work on the destro film
that just seems like the best combo in
the world best director best actor best
character yeah I'm a big destro fan he's
awesome originally it was rumoured the
Deathstroke would be going up against
the Dark Knight in the soul of Batman
film that was going to be directed by
Matt Reeves will still be directed by
Matt Reeves but unfortunately it looks
like Deathstroke is not gonna be a main
antagonist and more maybe the penguin
who knows those are just rumors but at
the very least we know Deathstroke is
out there and I'm happy and we know
Alexa's run around the world scheming
doing what he do but what about this
levy G's mentioning if it's what I think
it is I think we're about to see some
version of an evil Justice League on the
big screen
hell yeah fun fact this was actually
teased a little while ago by Joe
Manganiello on Twitter BAM look at that
photo look at shirt now that right there
is just one of the many teams of
villains in DC Comics Legion of Doom is
from the Super Friends cartoon from way
back when but also from legends of
tomorrow season two but doesn't stop
there you also got high Brotherhood of
Evil the crime syndicate from Earth 3
which is just literally evil
doppelgangers of like Superman Batman
Wonder Woman you name it but I think the
one we're gonna go with is the injustice
league my favorite let's focus on the
injustice league for just a second
mainly because the comic-book team
consists of Deathstroke and Lex Luthor
both in the classic comics and in the
new 52 my personal favorite because I
read that one it's really cool yeah cuz
they also save the world from the evil
Justice League I mentioned earlier and
it was amazing but I also we're going to
talk about this team mainly because it
consists of many popular villains that
will be in upcoming DC films have been
in the movies before or could be in the
ones that are in pre-production now in
the new 52 comics Lex Luthor assembles a
bizarro black atom Black Manta Captain
cold Catwoman test joke and Sinestro has
saved the world or they're all bad guys
it's real fun Batman is also there too
but let's not focus on him so far we
know Lex and Deathstroke exist in the DC
you as for upcoming movies we know that
black Adam is going to get his own solo
movie also he might make an appearance
in Suicide Squad - at least that's what
the rumors are right now that's what
he's talking about with Warner Brothers
but nothing's been confirmed what I'm
saying is it might make sense for him to
pop up in this in Justice League movie
or in Justice League - as for Black
Manta he will be played by Yaya
Dule martine ii in aquaman solo movie
set for that 2018 release date BAM there
you go hopefully he survives that movie
because villains don't always survive in
these DC movies also ocean master played
by Patrick Wilson survives that movie as
well he could make a very great addition
to this team as her captain cold unless
he makes an appearance in that rumored
flashpoint movie it might be a little
tough to introduce him in this group
film maybe Jai Courtney's Captain
Boomerang because people already know
him I found him pretty enjoyable in the
Suicide Squad I know he wasn't perfect
but I liked him we need a flash villain
as for Catwoman she could make an
appearance in that solo Batman movie but
is still in early pre-production so I'm
not sure who will be in that movie
exactly maybe not even Ben Affleck also
bizarre might be a tough one to pull off
without a Man of Steel 2 for those of
you who don't know who bizarro is he's
this faulty clone of Superman made by
Lex Luthor who like talks in Reverse not
like backwards he just says the opposite
of what he means like I love you it
means I hate you see it's confusing it
wouldn't really make sense in this group
movie to introduce a character like that
but hey guys fans don't get mad at me
because I love the character I just try
to be honest here with that we're left
with Sinestro I think we need another
shot at the all-out evil Sinestro from
the comics on the big screen I wish Mark
Strong would take another swing at him
because he's great I loved him in
Kingsman but if not give us some version
of Sinestro please put him in that Green
Lantern's movie the buddy cop movie
maybe they're hunting him down could be
cool we just need him on this in Justice
League but who would you like to see
Indian Justice League would you want
them to be in Justice League to going up
against Superman Batman you know
everybody or would you want them to have
their own movie let me know in the
comments down below I'd rather have them
in Justice League - I'll be honest
be sure to LIKE this video share it with
your friends and subscribe the new rock
stars for more content I'm at Sam bash
on Twitter tweet me your thoughts and
theories and I'll see you guys next time